IT'S GREAT SPEAKING TO YOU.
>> JOINING US NOW LIVE FROM
E.I.B., SOUTHERN COMMAND
HEADQUARTERS, THE MOST
LISTENED TO TALK RADIO HOST IN
THE HISTORY OF THE MEDIUM.
RADIO TALK SHOW LEGEND RUSH
LIMBAUGH.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> I AM FABULOUS!
IT'S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU
TONIGHT.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, FOR THOSE
THAT NEVER GOT YOU WITH HALF
MY BRAIN TIED BEHIND MY BACK,
IN A LOT OF WAYS YOU ARE LIKE
TRUMP.
YOU SAY THESE THINGS AND
PEOPLE BUBBLE AND FIZZ LIKE
ALKA-SELTZER.
THEY HAVE NO SENSE OF HUMOR.
I'M NOT SURE IF I GOT THROUGH.
DID WE GET STUCK ON THE THING?
YOU SAY CONTROVERSIAL THINGS
ALSO.
AND YOU ARE JOKING WHEN SAY
"HALF MY BRAIN TIED BEHIND MY
BACK."
>> WELL, NO.
ACTUALLY I DO.
I SPLIT MY SKULL OPEN AND I
TAKE HALF OF IT OUT AND I PUT
IT BEHIND MY BACK.
LIKE I SAY "TALENT ON LOAN
FROM GOD."
THESE PEOPLE ARE LIKE, "HE'S
CALLING HIMSELF GOD."
SEAN, I HAVE BEEN LISTENING TO
YOUR WHOLE SHOW.
THESE PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT TONIGHT DON'T
HAVE A SENSE OF RUMOR.
TO THEM, LIFE IS A WAR.
EVERY DAY OF THEIR LIVES IS A
BATTLE.
WE ARE THE ENEMY.
THEIR EFFORT IS TO ELIMINATE
US.
AL-QAEDA IS NOT THEIR ENEMY.
ISIS IS NOT THEIR ENEMY.
SOCIALISM IS NOT THEIR ENEMY,
COMMUNISM.
WE ARE.
CONSERVATIVE AND REPUBLICAN
AMERICA IN THEIR VIEW ARE THE
OBSTACLE IN THEIR WAY TO THEIR
DESIRE TO CREATE A
TOTALITARIAN STATE THAT THEY
THINK WILL BE A UTOPIA.
I WAS LISTENING TO YOU AND DON
JR. TALKING ABOUT THIS SHOULD
NEVER EVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
I HAVE TO CLARIFY.
IT IS NOT OVER.
IT IS STILL HAPPENING.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY AND THE
MEDIA AND ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
FROM THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
THAT RAN THIS SCANDAL ARE
STILL RUNNING IT.
THE OBJECTIVE REMAINS TO GET
DONALD TRUMP OUT OF OFFICE,
EITHER BY DRIVING THE NUMBERS
DOWN OR IMPEACHING HIM OR
DEFEATING HIM IN 2020.
TODAY THE "NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
THE STORY THAT THE MULE MAUL
MAUL -- MUELLER REPORT IS 300
PAGES AND THE BARR SUMMARY IS
FOUR PAGES.
THEREFORE, BARR IS LYING.
PELOSI, LITERALLY SAID WE
CANNOT TRUST THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
SO WHAT WE ARE LED TO BELIEVE
BY THE PEOPLE, THEY HAVE TO
FEED THEIR BEAST WITH THIS
FAKE NEWS CONSTANTLY.
THEY HAVE CREATED A MONSTER
THAT BELIEVES AND ABSORBS AND
NEEDS FAKE NEWS LIKE VAMPIRES
NEED YOUR BLOOD.
THERE IS EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" IS
LEADING THE EFFORT.
THE REST OF THE DRIVE-BY MEDIA
IS GOING TO PICK IT UP.
BECAUSE IT BELONGS THE
NARRATIVE THAT TRUMP IS
UNWORTHY.
THAT TRUMP CHEATED THAT WE
NEED TO REDO THE ELECTION
RESULTS IN 2016.
SO WE ARE BEING LED TO BELIEVE
THAT THIS REPORT DOES CONTAIN
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
BARR IS LYING ABOUT IT.
IF THIS IS SO SILLY, IF --
THIS IS SO SILLY.
IF IT CONTAINS EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION WHERE IS MUELLER ON
TELEVISION ALL NIGHT SAYING
WAIT A MINUTE, WAIT A MINUTE.
THAT IS NOT WHAT MY REPORT
SAYS.
MY REPORT SAYS THERE IS PLENTY
OF EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
I HAD ALL THE ANTI-HILLARY
PEOPLE ON MY STAFF AND WE
FOUND ALL KIND OF EVIDENCE AND
BARR IS LYING.
WHY ISN'T MUELLER DOING THAT
IF BARR IS LYING IN REPORT?
THIS IS AN ONGOING EFFORT TO
CONTINUE TO ATTACK AND IMPUGN
THE INTEGRITY AND THE DECENCY
AND THE QUALIFICATIONS OF
DONALD TRUMP TO BE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S NOT GOING TO STOP THE
MEDIA.
LOOK, LOOK AT THIS.
I TOLD THIS STORY ON THE RADIO
TODAY.
IF I HAD LIED TO MY AUDIENCE
FOR TWO YEARS, THAT I KNEW
HILLARY CLINTON WAS BEING
INVESTIGATED, I HAD SOURCES
AND SHE WAS GOING DOWN.
SHE WAS GOING TO BE LOCKED UP.
YOU CAN COUNT ON ME.
YOU CAN BELIEVE ME.
I'M HEARING IT FROM PEOPLE I
TRUST.
IT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
TWO YEARS.
EVERY DAY ON MY PROGRAM.
15 HOURS A WEEK.
I PUMMEL PEOPLE WITH THIS.
THEN IT TURNS TO OUT TO BE NOT
TRUE.
I'M FINISHED.
I CAN'T FACE MY AUDIENCE
AGAIN.
I'VE LIED TO THEM.
THEY WOULDN'T WANT ANYTHING TO
DO WITH ME.
I WOULD TRY TO APOLOGIZE.
BUT I WOULDN'T GET AWAY WITH
IT BECAUSE I WOULD HAVE
EXPLOITED THEM.
I WOULD HAVE USED THEM.
I WOULD HAVE TOYED THEM.
I WOULD HAVE MANIPULATED AND
LIED TO THEM.
THIS EXACT THING HAS HAPPENED
FROM MSNBC TO CNN TO THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" TO THE "WASHINGTON
POST."
THEY ARE LYING TO EVERYBODY
AND THEIR AUDIENCES DON'T SEEM
TO CARE.
JUST GIVE US MORE FAKE NEWS.
THEY WANT IT.
THEY CAN'T ACCEPT THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS NOT A TRAITOR.
THEY ARE UNHAPPY.
WE ARE DEALING WITH DERANGED
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT RATIONAL.
WE CAN'T DEAL WITH THEM
RATIONALLY.
KARL ROVE TODAY SAID
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU NEED TO
MOVE ON.
DON'T DO AN INVESTIGATION.
DON'T FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED.
SWING VOTERS DON'T CARE.
ONE THING THAT I HEARD THAT
YOU GUYS WERE DISCUSSING AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH, WE HAVE
GOT TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS.
WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE PEOPLE
NAMED.
THEY HAVE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
IF JAIL TIME IS CALLED FOR,
THEY NEED TO GO TO JAIL.
THEY KNOWINGLY LIED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE MEDIA WERE WILLINGLY
COMPLICIT.
THEY WERE NOT FOOLED.
THEY WANTED IT TO BE TRUE.
THEY RAN A SCAM.
THEY RAN AN EFFORT TO TRY TO
GET DONALD TRUMP THROWN OUT OF
OFFICE.
NORMALLY THEY ARE ABLE TO GET
RID OF THE REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS WHEN THEY WANT TO
BUT THEY FAILED WITH TRUMP.
SO NOW THEY ARE DOING A NEW
TOOK.
THE MUELLER REPORT MUST
CONTAIN SOME EVIDENCE.
IT'S 300 PAGES.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE
THIS UP.
THIS IS WHY THERE NEEDS TO
BE -- I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S A
SPECIAL COUNSEL OR CHARGING
PEOPLE BUT WE NEED TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS AND FIND
OUT JUST HOW HIGH UP, THE
OBAMA TOTEM POLE THIS GOES.
I THINK IT GOES ALL THE WAY UP
TO OBAMA.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT THIS.
BRENNAN, CLAPPER, ALL THE
PEOPLE IN HIS REGIME, THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE F.B.I., IT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO CALL IT THE
WORST SCANDAL IN THE WORLD.
THEY ALMOST GOT AWAY WITH
THIS, SEAN.
AND THE FACT THAT WE SAY IT
COULD NEVER BE ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
IT'S STILL HAPPENING.
THEY HAVEN'T CHANGED THEIR
TACTIC WHATSOEVER.
THE OBJECTIVE REMAINS.
GET RID OF TRUMP.
DEFEAT US.
HOWEVER THEY CAN.
>> Sean: I'M LISTENING VERY,
VERY CLOSELY TO WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING.
>> THAT WAS WITH HALF MY BRAIN
TIED BEHIND MY BACK, BY THE
WAY.
DID YOU SEE ME PUT IT --
>> Sean: TALENT ON LOAN FROM
GOD, PRAISES GOD IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
IT DOESN'T TAKE MUCH TO GET --
[LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW, I HAVE LISTENED TO
YOU.
YOU SYNDICATED THE LAST YEAR
OF RONALD REAGAN.
YOU HAVE BEEN A LEADER OF THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT.
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS SCARY.
THAT THIS IS AN ATTEMPTED
COUP.
>> IT IS!
IT IS TOTALLY SCARY.
I DON'T THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
THIS WAS NOT, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN -- DON'T DOUBT ME
HERE.
IT WAS NOT AN INVESTIGATION.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION.
ROBERT MUELLER TOOK THIS GIG
AND OPENED HIS INVESTIGATION
WITHOUT EVIDENCE.
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE.
HE WASN'T EVEN GIVEN A
SPECIFIC CRIME TO PURSUE.
IT WAS GO FIND A CRIME.
BECAUSE THERE WEREN'T ANY
CRIMES THAT HAD BEEN
COMMITTED.
BUT WHAT WE WENT JUST WENT
THROUGH WAS NOT AN
INVESTIGATION.
ROBERT MUELLER HAS KNOWN FOR A
MINIMUM, FOLKS, OF 18 MONTHS.
THAT THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
WHY DID HE NOT SHUT IT DOWN 18
MONTHS -- WHY DID HE TAKE THE
GIG?
HE TOOK THE JOB KNOWING THERE
WAS NO COLLUSION.
THE ONLY COLLUSION -- WE HAVE
SAID ITED ADED THAT THE ONLY
COLLUSION IS CLINTON WITH THE
DOSSIER.
BRENNAN MET WITH THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS YESTERDAY.
THIS ISN'T AT OVER AS FAR AS
THEY'RE CONCERNED.
BRENNAN PASSED THE DOSSIER TO
HARRY REID.
EVERYBODY THINKS IT'S
McCAIN.
McCAIN PLAYED A ROLE IN
THIS.
THIS IS NOT AN INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS A COUP.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO FIND THE
CRIME.
THE FACT THEY COULDN'T WITH
ALL OF THIS MONEY, AND 19
PEOPLE ON HIS INVESTIGATIVE
TEAM, AT LEAST THE LAWYERS WHO
WERE FROM THE ANTI-TRUMP CAMP.
THEY HAD DONORS TO HILLARY
CLINTON.
THEY COULDN'T FIND IT.
SEAN, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THAT THIS
PASSAGE IN THE MUELLER REPORT
WHERE IT SAYS, "NUMEROUS
ENTRITIES WERE MADE TO THE
RUSSIANS BY THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN."
THAT IS NOT WHAT HAPPENED.
THE F.B.I. ATTEMPTED TO PLANT
THE OWN INFORMERS IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
ONE NAMED STEPHEN HELPER,
CAMBRIDGE PROFESSOR MI H 6,
U.K.
THEY TRIED TO GET HIM HIRED IN
THE FOREIGN POLICY ADVISORY
ROLE IN THE CAMPAIGN.
FORTUNATELY, WHOEVER
INTERVIEWED HIM DIDN'T HIRE
HIM.
IF HE HAD BEEN HIRED AND THEY
TRIED TO GET TWO OTHER PEOPLE.
IF THEY HAD BEEN HIRED, GUESS
WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE DONE?
THEY WOULD HAVE STARTED
COMMUNICATING WITH THE RUSSIAN
AGENTS THEY KNOW.
THEN THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
COLLUSION THAT THE F.B.I. WAS
TRYING TO TO CREATE.
THERE WASN'T ANY.
THIS IS WORSE THAN ANYBODY IS
BEING LED TO BELIEVE IT IS.
BECAUSE IT'S BEING CALLED AN
INVESTIGATION.
AND TRUMP PASSED THE TEST.
THEY DIDN'T FIND ANYTHING.
THEY ARE NOT FINISHED.
THEY AREN'T THROUGH TRYING TO
GET RID OF DONALD TRUMP.
THEY ARE NOT THROUGH TRYING TO
OVERTURN ELECTION RESULTS OF
2016.
THEY ARE NEVER GOING TO FINISH
TRYING TO GET RID OF TRUMP.
EVEN IF HE IS ELECTED IN 2020.
THEY ARE SETTING UP THE
IMPEACHMENT NOW WITH ALL OF
THIS STUFF.
THAT IS WHY THESE PEOPLE NEED
TO BE POLITICALLY DEFEATED AND
POUNDED IN TO THE GROUND TO
THE POINT OF IRRELEVANCE.
THE WAY TO DO IT IS TO EDUCATE
AS MANY AMERICANS AS POSSIBLE
TO WHAT HAPPENED.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT BY MOVING
ON.
AND SAY OKAY, WELL, WE ESCAPE
THIS ONE, GANG.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
AGENDA ITEM HERE, WHICH BETTER
BE IMMIGRATION, BY THE WAY.
IT IS NOT FINISHED.
IT WASN'T AN INVESTIGATION.
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE EVER OF
COLLUSION.
IT SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEGUN.
ROSENSTEIN SHOULD NEVER HAVE
APPOINTED ANYBODY.
THE FISA WARRANTS TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN FOR
ILLEGAL.
THE JUDGES THERE WERE EITHER
COMPLICIT TO THIS OR THEY WERE
LIED TO.
AROUND NOW THEY DON'T CARE --
AND NOW THEY DON'T CARE.
WE HAVE A TWO-TIER JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
THE FOUNDATION OF THE COUNTRY
HAVE BEEN ATTACKED AND
ASSAULTED AND THE PEOPLE WHO
KNOW IT IN THE MAIN STREAM
MEDIA ARE COMPLICIT IN IT,
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO BLOW IT
UP AND EXPLAIN IT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE ARE AT A DANGEROUS POINT IN
THE HISTORY OF OUR NATION.
THERE IS JUST ONE GUY STANDING
UP AGAINST ALL OF THIS.
THAT IS TRUMP.
THERE IS NOT ANOTHER
REPUBLICAN THAT I KNOW OF --
MAYBE YOU DO, SEAN.
THERE IS NOT ANOTHER
REPUBLICAN THAT COULD HAVE
WITHSTOOD THAT COULD HAVE PUT
UP WITH TRUMP DID FOR ONE
WEEK.
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN SUING FOR
PEACE, GIVING UP, ACKNOWLEDGES
AND RESIGNED.
IT IS STROKE OF LUCK HERE THAT
WE HAVE HAD TRUMP TO PUT UP
WITH THIS.
BUT THE FACT THAT IT WAS
ATTEMPTED BY UNELECTED -- THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE APPARATUS
OF THIS COUNTRY, C.I.A.,
D.I.A., N.I.A., TURNED AGAINST
ONE FAMILY AND BY EXTENT HIS
SUPPORTERS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE HE HAD
THE AUDACITY TO WIN AND BEAT
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE UNELECTED PEOPLE.
THE ARROGANT, ELITE SNOBS IN
THE DEEP STATE, ADMINISTRATIVE
STATE, COULDN'T EBIDE IT --
ABIDE IT AND COULD NOT STOP.
THEY ARE SELLING THE BOOK ON
THE FACT THERE IS COLLUSION.
AND SCHIFF SAYING COLLUSION.
AND SWALWELL.
THIS OUGHT TO PROVE TO
EVERYBODY THIS IS AN ONGOING
POLITICAL PROJECT TO GET RID
OF TRUMP.
THEY DON'T CARE WHETHER OR NOT
THE RUSSIANS ACTUALLY SPIED OR
ACTUALLY AFFECTED THE ELECTION
BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
AND IF SOMEBODY WAS GIVEN THE
ORDER TO RIG A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, I DON'T EVEN THINK
IT'S POSSIBLE.
OBAMA EVERYONE SAID SO.
SO THIS WHOLE PREMISE IS
RIDICULOUS.
IT'S NOT LEGITIMATE.
YET, EVERYBODY IS DEALING WITH
THIS AS THOUGH IT'S A SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION.
WE DODGED A BULLET.
TRUMP --
IT WAS, IT'S NOT AN
INVESTIGATION.
THIS WAS AN ATTEMPT TO THROW
HIM OUT OF OFFICE.
JUST BECAUSE HE WON AND THEY
DIDN'T LIKE IT.
IT'S NO MORE COMPLICATED THAN
THAT.
>> Sean: THAT IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY MONOLOGUE.
YOU KNOW, RUSH --
>> Sean: NO TELEPROMPTER
HERE, SEAN.
>> YOU DID NOT.
THAT IS ALL EXTEMPORANEOUS --
THERE ARE A FEW OF US AT FOX.
PRIMETIME, LAURA, TUCKER, FOX
& FRIENDS.
YOU, MARK IN TALK RADIO.
I HAVE HAD ENSEMBLE CAST IN
THE SHOW THAT HAS DUG DEEP.
THED 9.9% OF -- 99.9% OF THE
MEDIA DRIVE-BYES BOUGHT IT,
SOLD IT, HOOK, LINE AND
SINKER.
AND AS THEY ALWAYS DO, GET IT
WRONG.
>> THEY DIDN'T BUY ANYTHING.
THEY DIDN'T BUY ANYTHING.
THEY WERE IN ON IT.
THEY DON'T FEEL ANY REMORSE.
THEY'RE UNHAPPY THEY FAILED.
THEY DON'T CARE THEY LIED TO
THEIR AUDIENCES.
THEY ARE NOT WORRIED IF THE
AUDIENCES WILL REJECT THEM.
AUDIENCES NOW DON'T TRUST THEM
OR BELIEVE THEM.
THEY WERE IN ON IT.
THEY WERE COMPLICIT.
THEY CONSIDERED THEMSELVES TO
BE PART OF THIS ELITE GANG
INSIDE THE BELTWAY THAT RUNS
THE TOWN.
THEY WERE IN ON IT.
ALL IT IS NOW IS THEY HAVE
FAILED.
YOUR KNOW, I SAW SOMETHING
WHERE MSNBC PRIMETIME HAD A
SUDDEN INEXPLICABLE 20% LOSS
IN AUDIENCE ONE NIGHT THIS
WEEK.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
YOU ARE A BROADCAST
PROFESSIONAL.
I'M A NATURALLY TALENTED,
HIGHLY TRAINED BROADCAST
SPECIALIST.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
WHEN SHE LOSES, RACHEL MADDOW,
OR WHEN THEY LOSE 20% OF THE
AUDIENCE JUST BECAUSE THIS
THING BOMBED OUT, IT TELLS ME
THAT THE AUDIENCE IS THERE NOT
BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE BUT
BECAUSE OF THE FAKE NEWS.
WHEN THE FAKE NEWS BOMBS OUT,
WHEN ALL THE EXPECTATIONS THAT
TRUMP IS GOING TO JAIL, TRUMP
IS GOING DOWN.
WELL, HE IS NOT.
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
THEY FAILED.
SO MSNBC CAN NOT SERVE THEIR
EXPECTATIONS ANYMORE.
AND THEIR HOSTS ARE NOT ENOUGH
TO HOLD THE AUDIENCE.
IT'S NOTHING OTHER THAN A
TESTIMONY TO -- TESTAMENT TO
THE FACT THEY CREATE AN
AUDIENCE THAT WANTS TO BELIEVE
A BUNCH OF LIES.
WANTS TO BELIEVE THE WORST
ABOUT THE COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY
GET UP EVERY DAY DOING THAT
ALREADY.
NOW WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO?
THAT IS WHY THE PEOPLE COME UP
WITH THE NEW HOOK.
THE MUELLER REPORT IS 300
PAGES.
BARR SUMMARY IS FOUR.
THERE HAS TO BE COLLUSION.
NOW THEY'RE TRYING TO WORK
BACK UP AND LYING TO THEM
AGAIN.
CONTINUALLY LYING TO THEM.
MISREPRESENTING THE TRUTH.
MANIPULATING THESE PEOPLE.
IT'S NO WONDER WE CAN'T COME
TOGETHER, SEAN.
WHOEVER IS IT THAT WATCHES THE
DRIVE-BY MEDIA AND THE
PRIMETIME CABLE ON THE LEFT,
THERE IS NO WAY WE CAN HAVE
ANYTHING IN COMMON WITH THEM.
THEY ARE BEING TOLD, THEY ARE
BEING INSTRUCTED TO LITERALLY
HATE THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE IT'S
UNJUST, IT'S UNFAIR, IT WAS
FOUNDED IMMORALLY OR
SOMETHING.
THIS IS A DIRE CIRCUMSTANCE.
WHEN FACTS AND TRUTH DON'T
EVEN HAVE A CHANCE WITH A
CERTAIN SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION.
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN TRAINED
AND CONDITIONED TO WANT TO
BELIEVE THE WORST AND WANT --
YOU WOULD THINK THEY WOULD BE
HAPPY THAT THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T COLLUDE.
THAT THE RUSSIANS DIDN'T
DETERMINE THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION.
BUT NOW LOOK WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE EVEN TO THAT.
EVERY ELECTION GOING FORWARD
IS TAINTED.
THE RUSSIANS.
DID THEY -- EVERY TIME THE
DEMOCRATS LOSE, IT'S GOING TO
BE SOME EXTERNAL FACTOR.
IT CAN'T BE THEY LOST BECAUSE
THEY WERE REJECTED.
NO.
IT'S GOING TO BE THE RUSSIANS
OR SOME OTHER FOREIGN AGENT
GOT IN THERE AND CHEATED AND
STOLE IT FROM WHOEVER THEIR
NEXT NOMINEE IS.
THAT IS WHY THERE SHOULDN'T BE
ANY ATTEMPT TO CROSS THE
AISLE.
MAKE COMMON GROUND.
WE DON'T HAVE COMMON GROUND.
THEY NEED TO BE SU MELLED IN
THE SPLIT -- PUMMELED IN THE
POLITICAL DIRT.
AND BECOME ACKNOWLEDGED AS THE
MINORITY THEY ARE.
I'M DEAD SERIOUS ABOUT THIS.
DEAD SERIOUS ABOUT IT.
WE ARE AT A CRISIS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
BECAUSE THE MEDIA HAS GIVEN UP
EVEN THE PRETENSE OF THE
OBJECTIVITY.
THEY ARE NOW LEFTIST,
ACTIVISTS PUSHING AN AGENDA.
THIS ONE FAILED SO ON TO THE
NEXT ONE.
>> Sean: AS I LISTEN TO YOU
REALLY CLOSELY.
THIS IS ONGOING.
BUT THERE IS ANOTHER FACTOR.
LOOK TO 2020.
NEW GREEN DEAL.
WHAT DO YOU SEE ON THE HORIZON
POLITICALLY?
>> WELL, NEW GREEN DEAL.
OKAY.
LOOK.
HERE IT IS.
WHAT IS THE SELLING POINT OF
THE GREEN NEW DEAL THAT WE
HAVE 12 YEARS TO LIVE.
THAT 5% OF THE WORLD'S
POPULATION, BECAUSE OF THE
UNITED STATES IS TO BLAME,
RIGHT?
IT'S THE UNITED STATES THAT
HAS TO ENGAGE IN ALL THE
FIXES.
THE UNITED STATES HAS TO DO
ALL THE REPARATIONS.
THE UNITED STATES HAS TO FIX
IT.
BECAUSE WE'RE DESTROYING THE
CLIMATE.
5% OF THE WORLD'S POPULATION.
WE HAVE ONLY GOT 12 YEARS.
IF WE'VE ONLY GOT 12 YEARS,
THEN WE BETTER JUST THROW
EVERYTHING OUT THE WINDOW AND
START DOING EVERYTHING WE WANT
TO DO EVERY DAY BECAUSE WE ARE
GOING TO BE DEAD IN 12 YEARS
IF WE DON'T ENACT THEIR
STUPID -- IT'S ABSURD.
THE IDEA THAT ANYBODY COULD
BELIEVE THIS INTELLECTUALLY IF
THEY TAKE A MOMENT -- BY THE
WAY, HOW MANY, I REMEMBER IN
1988, I'M WATCHING "THIS WEEK
NEEDS DAVID BRINKLEY."
THEY HAVE A GOT ON THERE.
"WE'VE ONLY GOT 20 YEARS TO
SAVE THE WORLD."
"CAN YOU PROVE THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING?"
"NO, BUT WE CAN'T TAKE THE
CHANCE THAT IT ISN'T."
THEN IN 1988, WE HAVE TEN
YEARS IF WE DON'T FIX THE
OCEANS WE'LL DIE.
SOMETHING THAT IS RECYCLED, WE
DON'T EVEN HAVE THE POWER TO
IMPACT THE CLIMATE.
WE CAN'T CHANGE IT FOR BETTER
OR WORSE.
BUT IT IS CONSTANTLY CHANGING.
ALL WE CAN DO IS ADAPT TO IT.
WE ARE THE BEST IN THE WORLD
AT THAT.
GREEN NEW DEAL, THEY CAN'T
EVEN SUPPORT IT IN THE SENATE
WHEN IT COMES UP FOR A VOTE.
IT'S ANOTHER LIE.
IT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HOW
THEY ARE MANIPULATING AND
MISREPRESENTING THEIR
UNFORTUNATELY SICK BASE.
THE SICK BASE WANTS TO HEAR
THIS.
THEY WANT TO HEAR THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DIE.
THEY WANT TO HEAR THE
APOCALYPSE IS COMING.
THEY WANT TO HEAR THAT LIFE IS
NOTHING BUT ETERNAL SUFFERING
AND THEY WANT SOMEONE TO PAY
THE PRICE FOR IT.
IF IT'S RICH, BILLIONAIRES,
CORPORATIONS, IF IT'S THE
REPUBLICANS OR WHOEVER ELSE.
SO THESE PEOPLE ARE HAPPY.
THEY ARE HAPPY TO LIE.
TO THEIR OWN VOTERS AND TELL
THEM LIFE ENDS IN 12 YEARS,
UNLESS WE DO WHAT?
RETROFIT EVERY BUILDING, STOP
COWS FROM FARTING.
STOP EATING -- IT'S, IT IS
INSANE!
>> Sean: RUSH --
>> YOU CAN GO THROUGH -- YES.
I KNOW, I HAVE DIARRHEA OF THE
MOUTH.
I'M SORRY.
>> Sean: I REALLY HAVE ONE
MORE QUESTION.
I HAVE TO CHARGE RATES.
THEY'LL KILL ME.
CAN YOU STAY FOR ONE MORE
QUESTION?
>> YEAH, YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
HAPPY TO DO IT.
>> Sean: AS WE CONTINUE OUR
EXCLUSIVE RUSH LIMBAUGH, RUSH,
THIS MAY GO DOWN AS YOUR
GREATEST RANT EVER.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT BECAUSE
OF -- NO, NO, I'M SERIOUS, I'M
BEING EXSTARTLY --
EXTRAORDINARILY OBJECTIVE.
>> THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU HAVE A LOT OF TIME.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU ARE VERY GENEROUS.
>> Sean: THIS IS IMPORTANT
WHAT I'M GOING TO ASK YOU.
YOU SAY WE MUST DEFEAT THEM
20.
20 IS AROUND THE CORN
TAXPAYERS -- DEFEAT THEM.
2020 IS AROUND THE CORNER.
HOW?
>> THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO BE
RE-ELECTED AND THE ONE THING
HE NEEDS TO ZERO IN ON IS
IMMIGRATION.
HE WANTS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
TO BECOME KNOWN AS THE PARTY
OF HEALTHCARE.
THAT IS A TANGIBLE THING THAT
REALLY MATTERS TO EVERY HUMAN
BEING IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT I'M TELLING YOU HE WAS
ELECTED ON IMMIGRATION AND
STOPPING IT.
WE SUSPENDED IMMIGRATION IN
THE UNITED STATES TO STOP THEM
COMING ILLEGALLY FROM ELLIS
ISLAND AND ALL OF THAT.
THEY HAD TO ASSIMILATE AND
JOIN THE CULTURE.
THAT IS NOT HAPPENING.
WE HAVE A PARTY OPENING THE
BORDER FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE RULE OF
LAW?
I THINK THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
SHUT THE BORDER.
IF HE SHUTS THE BORDER, BUILDS
THE WALL, THERE IS NOBODY WHO
CAN BEAT HIM IN 2020.
IT REMAINS THE ISSUE FOR THE
VAST MAJORITY OF
FREEDOM-LOVING,
CONSTITUTION-LOVING,
AMERICAN-LOVING CITIZENS.
IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN, THE
COUNTRY THAT WE KNOW AND
LOVE -- THERE IS ALWAYS GOING
TO BE AN AMERICA.
BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO REMAIN
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC AS
FOUNDED IF WE DON'T GET AHEAD.
IT'S NOTHING ABOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT MAKES THEM BAD.
IT'S THE RULE OF LAW.
ONCE, ONCE YOU ALLOW PEOPLE TO
BREAK THE LAW, ONCE YOU SIGNAL
LAWLESSNESS IS OKAY, WHERE
DOES IT STOP?
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
CONDITIONED TO ASSIMILATE.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT THEM
TO ASSIMILATE.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO KEEP
THEM POOR AND KEEP THEM
DEPENDENT SO THEY ALWAYS VOTE
DEMOCRAT.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT
COMPASSIONATE PEOPLE.
THEY NEED A PERMANENT
UNDERCLASS.
THEY WANT THE PEOPLE TO COME
IN HERE, REMAIN POOR, REMAIN
IN NEED.
IF THEY ARE GOING TO BE HERE,
LET'S TURN THEM IN TO
PRODUCTIVE PEOPLE THAT CAN
HELP THIS COUNTRY GROW.
BUT RIGHT NOW, WE'VE GOT TO
STOP THE FLOW.
IF TRUMP DOES THAT, SEAN, WITH
A WALL OR SHUTTING THE BORDER
FOR A LITTLE WHILE TO MAKE
SURE WE GET A HANDLE ON THOSE
WHO ARE IN THE COUNTRY NOW,
NOBODY CAN BEAT HIM.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO THE
OTHER ISSUE.
THAT IS, THE ECONOMY, FOREIGN
POLICY.
YOU KNOW, HERE IS THE BIGGER
QUESTION.
WHERE IS THE BACKBONE OF OTHER
REPUBLICANS?
I'M NOT A REPUBLICAN.
I'M NOT REGISTERED REPUBLICAN.
I'M A CONSERVATIVE.
I THINK THEY ARE WEAK.
WHERE IS THEIR BACKBONE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE TALK
ABOUT THIS A LOT.
EVERY TIME WE GET TOGETHER.
LOOK, THE REPUBLICANS FOR THE
FIRST NINE MONTHS OF TRUMP'S
FIRST YEAR THOUGHT, THEY
BELIEVED THIS SCANDAL CRAP,
AND THEY THOUGHT TRUMP WAS
GONE.
SO THEY WOULDN'T GET BEHIND
THE AGENDA.
HALF OF THEM DIDN'T WANT HIM
TO WIN.
LOOK AT ALL THE REPUBLICANS
THAT RESIGNED.
OSTENSIBLY BECAUSE THEY WERE
LOSING THEIR COMMITTEE
CHAIRMANSHIPS.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE SUFFERED THE
MASSIVE MID-TERM LOSS IF SO
MANY HADN'T RESIGNED.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS NOT
UNIFIED.
AMERICAN CONSERVATISM IS NOT
SO RIGHT NOW, TRUMP REMAINS
THE UNIFYING FIGURE OR AT
LEAST THE BLUNT FORCE FIGURE
THAT -- LOOK, EVERYBODY WANTS
TO BE IN THE BRIGHT LIGHTS OF
WINNING.
EVEN THE REPUBLICANS YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
THEY WILL BE GLAD TO SHOW UP
WHEN THE FIGHTING IS OVER AND
SHAKE HANDS AND PUT THEIR
HANDS IN THE AIR AND THE
BRIGHT LIGHTS AND ACT LIKE
THEY PLAYED A ROLE IN IT.
MAYBE SO.
BUT WAITING AROUND FOR THEM TO
GET ON BOARD IS, I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE THE LUXURY TO DO THAT.
WE HAVE TO BRING THEM ON
BOARD.
LIKE WE HAVE TO BRING THE
SWING VOTERS TO OUR SIDE.
NOT GO DEFENSIVE.
AND TRY NOT TO OFFEND ANYBODY
AND HOPE WE SHOW THEM WE ARE
NICE PEOPLE.
IF WE HAVEN'T PROVEN WE ARE
NICE PEOPLE AFTER ALL OF THESE
YEARS, IT'S A LOST CAUSE.
WE HAVE TO ENGAGE IN ISSUES
THAT MATTER MOST TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND WILL
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES, MAKE THEM
FEEL TRUST AND HOPEFUL ABOUT
THEIR COUNTRY AND THEIR
FUTURE.
THERE ARE GOBS OF PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO FEEL THIS WAY.
GOBS OF PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT
WANT TO BE PROUD OF THE
COUNTRY.
I JUST TAP INTO IT AND MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
YEP, YEP, YEP THERE.
-- YEP.
THERE I GO AGAIN.
>> Sean: LISTEN.
THANK YOU.